change lives change lives change
organizations change
organiz change the
world so this is a what psychologists
call an attributional retraining
intervention and that just means that
we're trying to change the attributions
that people make for the negative events
that happen to them so when your friends
go out without you if they they they
exclude you or they leave you behind you
don't conclude necessarily that it it
means you don't belong in general so
what happens in the interventions is
that students get information these are
um in some of our studies College
freshmen uh or first year students in
engineering or um or students making a
transition to Middle School um they get
information from older students about
what their experiences were like uh
going into that that new environment and
the older students they hear about say
that they worried at first about their
belonging students of all ethnicities
different gender groups worried at first
about their belonging they wondered if
they belong they had negative events
happen to them but that's just part of
the normal transition to college for
example that's just part of what it
means to to to go through that difficult
transition for participating students
when they uh learn this information they
can uh infer that when these negative
events happen to them when they have
negative social events happen when they
worry about their belonging it doesn't
mean that they don't belong or that
their group doesn't belong it's just
part of the difficulty of of that
transition for everybody so that changes
people's attributions for those negative
events and what we find uh in our
research is that this has uh a very uh
significant effect on students academic
achievement so um when we did this
intervention with African-American and
and white uh College freshman in a
predominantly white uh University
setting the intervention delivered in
students freshman year improved students
grades African-American students grades
all the way through senior year what it
did was it it changed uh the the
trajectory of their achievement over
time time it didn't just automatically
improve their outcomes um whole stock it
led helped them to get on a positive
cycle where each term they did better
and better and and had a positive slope
over time in addition we found that a
factor that accounted for this was was
really this change in Social conrol so
in the in the first week after the
intervention in student freshman year we
ask them uh each day to tell us what
kinds of events happened to them what
good and bad events happened to them and
how they how they felt like they
belonged that at that time what we found
was that the intervention reduced the
degree to which when people had bad days
they felt like they didn't belong so for
African-American students in the control
condition when they had a bad day they
concurrently reported that they didn't
feel like they belonged and the
treatment prevented that from happening
it helped them continue to feel that
they belonged even when they had the the
bad day in other research we find that
with women in engineering uh this kind
of inter intervention increases women's
um confidence in their ability to handle
daily School stressors uh it makes them
have more State Higher and more stable
uh self-esteem in addition in with women
in engineering especially women in
heavily male-dominated engineering
Majors Majors with fewer than 20% women
uh the intervention helps the women
develop more friendships with men in
engineering so it it it helps them over
time through a variety of processes to
feel more at home in that environment
and that's really important for
achievement I think a lot of the same
kinds of psychological processes may be
uh similar in workplace situations as in
school situations when you go into a new
especially a demanding uh fast-paced
work environment people will readily
wonder you know what what's this place
like how do people work here how are
they going to relate to me if you're
going into a work setting where you have
special reasons or extra reasons to
wonder about whether other people will
value you and include you you and
respect your you and your abilities in
that setting I think people may
experience similar kinds of experiences
there's a lot of um specialized
psychological uh techniques here that
are being used to deliver the message
persuasively and effectively and one is
that it's not remedial so we're not
telling people that we think you need
help here's the help we're going to give
you instead we think we tell people we
think you're an expert and we want to
enlist your expertise in helping
somebody else another audience that you
care about we also use uh what we call
saying is believing exercises so we
don't just tell people the information
and trust them to run with it instead we
ask them to write about this we give
them the information we ask them to
write about how this process is true how
this process of worrying about your
belonging at first but overcoming those
worries is true for them to connect it
to their own experience and then to
advocate for that to an audience that
they care about to next year's freshman
as part of this phenomenon is that uh
people really feel like they're the only
one and everybody's feeling like they're
the only one I taught a freshman seminar
class in the fall quarter one year where
at one point in the class I asked the
students to take 10 minutes and just
write about the difficulties they were
experiencing in their transition to
college these kids have been on campus
for maybe a month and then I I collected
them I didn't had them write their names
on them I I mixed them all up and then I
redistributed them to the students and I
had each student read one of these from
one of their classmates and what was so
striking was uh how each of these things
you only had to read or three describe
just in eloquent just articulate sort of
emotive language about the the feelings
of of of sort of loneliness the
struggles the the challenges that these
students are facing I mean these I mean
going to college in for many people is
you know leaving your home Community
you're going to a new place your high
school friends you know are largely not
there if if at all you're living in an
entirely new environment you might be in
a different region of the country
the academic world is very different how
you do well what it takes to do well is
very different than in high school and
so these students wrote this and it was
so powerful to hear it was powerful for
me but it was especially powerful for
the students because you could just feel
that this thing that they each felt was
just just unto them was was all of us
was all of them change lives change
lives change
organiz
organiz change the world